New York Times Science columnist John
Tierney he's written about behavior and
communication and joins us at the table
hey John
hi what does it say that we now need
social psychology tips we need to have
you here the day before Thanksgiving
they help us out what does that say
about us
well people take it so seriously you
know they always said don't talk
politics or religion at the dinner table
and I think for a lot of people today
you know politics has become kind of a
religion yeah the latest study shows
that a lot of families have cut their
dinner down by an hour yeah because they
really want to avoid this so you're here
to say what to all of us you know don't
get into political arguments the
expecting the Windom done well right but
don't expect to win them by facts and
logic you know because we think we can
do that but but these political opinions
are really based on gut feelings and
what social psychologists call moral
intuitions and liberals and
conservatives just have really different
gut concepts of what's fair what's not
fair what's sacred what's taboo and you
know you can't change those feelings so
you're not going to change their minds
and because of that moral connection
that's why people get so hurt so fast
right it's not just an abstract fact
you're going to the heart of who they
are right it's who they are and what
tribe they belong to a group they're
part of you know so just you know try to
avoid it you know and try to be tactful
remember that not everyone at the table
may share your opinion of Donald Trump
or Nancy Pelosi don't use facts and
logic go what are you supposed to use I
think that you know don't try to win the
argument I mean try to get something out
of the discussion instead of telling
people that they're wrong and ask them
questions I mean you might learn
something from even the weirdest member
of your family and if you have the right
question if you ask the right question
that they might even rethink their
position you get more that way than just
coming right at them and telling them
they're wrong so what happens once
things are heated how do you defuse the
situation I think you know look for some
common ground some little things that
you know both sides can agree on and
then quickly change the subject like
this cranberries are great where did you
get them you know that kind of thing
right or store up that's so interesting
well you could store up some facts about
interesting things that are happening
elsewhere in the world for them to talk
about also yeah get them to talk about
themselves right right exactly yeah I
mean that's people's favorite topic is
themselves and if you ask them enough
they talk enough they'll think you're
the most charming conversationalist
here's a question people may remember
the Laurel yawning debate where people
heard two different things and you
couldn't argue somebody out of the
difference of what they were hearing is
that essentially the way we process
these political arguments exactly
because we've got these different gut
feelings and so and if you see things
differently from this different moral
standpoint you just can't you can't
cross that divide make sure to have a
dell downloaded on your phone or follow
the advice of tony moran t in the studio
that just says shut the bike up does
everyone just be quiet and eat how about
that
[Laughter]